depuis l'automne dernier le malheur
s'acharne sur Cristina Bodet son
conjoint et ses trois enfants
inondé deux fois en huit mois leur
appartement sans la moisissure sous le
plancher au bon milieu du salon une
pompe à les surplus d'eau le
propriétaire veut pas rénover tant qu'on
est ici
il me le très bien fait de comprendre
refoulement des goûts les empêche
d'utiliser la salle de bain et depuis le
début mai la toilette on doit faire des
allers-retours jusqu'au parc la douche
on essaie d'y aller le plus souvent chez
un de mes amis c'est dans ces conditions
que la famille devra vivre jusqu'à la
fin juin parce qu'ensuite elle sera
obligée de quitter son logement le
propriétaire a décidé de le reprendre je
trouve tellement que c'est horrible de
mettre une famille à l'extérieur de du
logement surtout dans les circonstances
dans lesquelles je suis c'est
complètement horrible de faire ça tu
sais ils devront abandonner leur 5 et
demi de Joliette qui louait pour 600
dollars par mois où est-ce qu'on va
s'éteint je sais pas pour l'instant je
sais pas impossible de trouver un
appartement dans le secteur
la grande majorité des logements
disponibles sont dans des constructions
neuves et louer trop cher pour ses
moyens j'ai regardé Juliette
Saint-Charles-Borromée saint Thomas
sainte Mélanie Finlande Sainte-Julienne
j'ai regardé vraiment partout là je sens
un sac ennemis c'est 1700 1800 puis j'en
ai vu tout à l'heure à 2004 là sur sur
Internet là c'est
impossible à payer et là la crise du
logement est maintenant bien installée
en périphérie de la métropole dans des
régions autrefois épargnées comme la
naudière c'est pas uniquement un vrai
dans les municipalités qui sont proches
de Montréal comme Repentigny ou
Terrebonne c'est vrai aussi un peu
partout dans la région y compris dans le
Nord dans un marché équilibré le taux
d'inoccupation et de 3% l'an dernier il
s'est établi à 2,3% sur l'île de
Montréal et à 1,3% en banlieue trouver
un logement y est encore plus difficile
beaucoup de gens qui étaient Lille pour
aller lui en banlieue pendant la
pandémie c'est de l'humain de la
pression sur le marché locatif mais
aussi c'est de plus en plus de styles
d'Achille propriétés les hausses de
prêts ont été vertigineuses pendant la
pandémie ce qui fait en que les gens
ménagent à Merlin locataire plus
longtemps le loyer moyen des
appartements de deux chambres à atteint
1000 dollars par mois l'an dernier à
Montréal il dépasse les 1060 dollars
dans les couronnes Nord et Sud mais si
on regarde seulement les logements
vacants remis sur le marché c'est encore
plus cher
1355 dollars dans la métropole
1590 en banlieue vous avez quitté votre
logement et que le propriétaire n'a
peut-être profiter de faire des
rénovations ou possiblement regarder les
comparables du marché dans les alentours
on parle d'augmentation de loyer dans ce
cas-là de 14 à 15%. selon les prévisions
de la Société canadienne d'hypothèques
et de logements les loyers grimperont
globalement de 10% dans le Grand
Montréal cette année si le résultat du
déséquilibre entre l'offre et la demande
on ne construit pas assez de nouveaux
logements
les locataires se présentent souvent par
dizaines lorsqu’un appartement est
alloué les propriétaires ont le gros
bout du bâton bien souvent des gens qui
vont offrir de payer plus que ce que qui
était déjà affiché alors que le montant
qui était affichée déjà une augmentation
extrêmement importante par rapport à ce
que payer l'ancien locataire il faut
reconnaître que la pression et les
fortes et tant les locataires et les
propriétaires exercent une pression dans
le marché actuel la semaine dernière le
gouvernement le goût a déposé un projet
de loi qui rendra les évictions plus
contraignantes pour les propriétaires
mais du même souffle il leur donne carte
blanche pour s'opposer aux sessions de
bail parfois vu comme étant un moyen de
prévenir les hausses de loyer abusives
lorsque locataire qui est un logement ce
projet de loi-là c'est pas une solution
à la crise du logement ce qu'on a besoin
au Québec c'est de relancer la
construction de diversifier partout au
Québec l'offre en logement communautaire
sociale aborda
atteint de fibromyalgie Claude pilon vit
une rente de la CNE SST il habite depuis
un an dans ce 3 et demi situé dans le
sous-sol d'une maison de Mascouche son
loyer vient de grimper après de 1000
dollars par mois sans compter
l'électricité le prix de revient à
Madame au côté et de 685 dollars pour
une location
identique quand il a signé son bail la
case indiquant le montant du loyer payé
par l'ancienne locataire de son logement
était vide la propriété a tout fait pour
pas que je sache même que je ne puisse
pas rencontrer la locataire précédente
il aimerait déménager
mais ne trouve rien d'assez abordable et
prix ça a aucun bon sens ça va
représenter plus de 50%
de mon revenu c'est inacceptable les
locataires par peur ou par mes
connaissances de un droit accepte des
augmentations de loyer n'importe comment
pour finalement se rendre compte que le
budget fonctionne pas la détresse est à
ce point grande chez certains locataires
qui craignent se retrouver à la rue
qu'action logement la naudière accrue
bon de mettre ce message sur son
répondeur
dans quel état d'esprit sont ces
locataires là stress anxiété dépression
nommer les taux ces émotions-là sont
toutes là il y a une petite lueur
d'espoir pour Christina Bodet sa famille
a été acceptée par le programme de
suppléments au loyer qui couvrira 75%
des coûts de son prochain logement
sont certains d'avoir un certain montant
par le gouvernement je me dis tu sais au
moins ils vont peut-être prendre la
chance de d'y aller avec nous vu que on
est assuré d'avoir un certain MONT ant
qui soit payé et si ça ne fonctionne pas
avant le 1er juillet la famille un plan
B allez vivre dans une roulotte